[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys und
>> ELA: Elas Welt!
>> SALLY: Ja, heute stehen wir zwei hier an der Front
und möchten etwas Tolles backen.
Eine Zuschauerin hat sich ein Rezept gewünscht.
Ich musste das erst mal googeln
und auch die Aussprache googeln.
Es heißt Khachapuri.
Und es ist ein georgisches Gericht.
Ich musste
– okay, ich gebe echt zu,
ihr wisst, ich bin...
Ich habe viel Stärken,
aber ich habe auch eine große Schwäche
und zwar ist das die Geografie.
Und ich musste erst mal Georgien googeln.
Wobei eine Freundin mal gesagt hat...
Du lachst jetzt, aber es ist halt echt so.
Ich dachte mir so: "Wo liegt Georgien? Wo liegt Georgien?
Vielleicht bei Island?
Vielleicht..." Keine Ahnung wo.
Ich habe es einfach nicht mit Geografie.
Okay, ich habe mich noch nie damit beschäftigt.
Jetzt weiß ich aber,
Georgien liegt im Nordosten der Türkei,
also – wartet, ich mache es für euch – einmal hier.
Wenn hier die Türkei ist,
ist hier Georgien,
grenzt also direkt an die Türkei.
Und eine Freundin von uns, die Sabine,
die war da sogar schon mal
und hat so davon geschwärmt,
dass ich gesagt habe:
"Mensch, da müssen wir unbedingt mal hin."
Jetzt weiß ich, wo es liegt.
Und vielleicht können wir irgendwann
wieder das Land verlassen.
Also können wir auch irgendwann
hoffentlich dahin reisen.
Und da gibt es eine Rezept, Ela, und das heißt Khachapuri.
Und ich dachte mir noch,
als ich das dann gegoogelt habe,
dachte ich mir noch, das sieht aus wie die türkischen Pide.
Und ich meine, es liegt ja nahe,
dass dann angrenzende Länder
so die ähnlichen Sitten und Bräuche,
die ähnlichen Rezepte haben.
Also das ist ein Brot gefüllt mit Käse,
ist nicht so genau wie Pide.
>> ELA: Mama, sag mir mal alle Zutaten.
>> SALLY: Ich sage dir jetzt alle Zutaten, okay?
Und deswegen werden wir das heute zubereiten.
Heute habe ich die fleißige Helferin Ela dabei
und dann wird das natürlich ganz wunderbar gelingen.
Jetzt machen wir erst mal den Hefeteig.
Für den Teig nehme ich einen Würfel Hefe,
einen Teelöffel Zucker,
250 Gramm warmes Wasser,
900 Gramm Mehl,
– ich nehme jetzt hier ein Dinkelmehl –
250 Gramm warme Milch,
zwei Teelöffel Salz,
120 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl.
>> ELA: Sollen wir es da reintun?
>> SALLY: Also eigentlich war ja gar nicht geplant,
dass du mir bei dem Rezept hilfst.
Jetzt übernimmst du einfach wieder alles, nicht?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Guck mal. Jetzt kannst du die Hefe hier reingeben ins Wasser.
>> ELA: Damit?
>> SALLY: Jetzt machen wir Brotteig.
Okay, jetzt wirst du so ein richtiger Bäcker.
Da kommt Zucker dazu.
>> ELA: Da war noch ein bisschen drin.
>> SALLY: Ja, noch ein bisschen.
Zucker.
Super! Und jetzt verrühren.
>> ELA: Ja!
>> SALLY: Ganz vorsichtig.
Guck mal, nicht so arg drücken.
Sonst spritzt es gleich raus.
Also am besten so ein bisschen streicheln.
Und dann löst sich die Hefe gleich auf.
Und festhalten, ja?
Ich hoffe, ihr habt zu Hause auch so einen fleißigen Bäcker,
einen Bäckerlehrling.
Hm?
>> ELA: Ja. Oi!
>> SALLY: Oi!
>> ELA: Ups!
>> SALLY: Geht es?
>> ELA: Ja.
Auch fertig.
>> SALLY: Zeig mal.
Soll ich mal gucken?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Weil die Hefe, die klebt immer so, gell?
Deswegen muss man das Glas gut festhalten.
Zack, zack, zack und dann geht es irgendwie.
>> ELA: Soll ich?
Die Hefe ist ge-
aufgelöst.
>> SALLY: Ja, die...
Guck mal, da ist noch ein bisschen dran
am Schneebesen.
>> ELA: Das ist doch kein Schneebesen!
>> SALLY: Ein Tellerbesen.
>> ELA: Ein Tellerbesen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> ELA: Ich glaube, der ist jetzt sauber.
>> SALLY: Guck mal.
Und dann kannst du es hier reinlegen.
Super!
>> ELA: Warum? >> SALLY: Gut.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt darfst du
das Hefewasser in die Maschine schütten.
>> ELA: Okay.
>> SALLY: In die Schüssel.
Man kann den Teig natürlich auch mit der Hand verkneten.
Aber die Ela, die schafft das ja super.
>> ELA: Okay.
Und die Maschine ist auch brav.
>> SALLY: Warte. Warte.
>> ELA: Die Maschine ist sehr brav.
>> SALLY: Ja, die ist brav.
Guck mal, da war noch ein bisschen Hefe drin.
Die geben wir auch noch rein.
>> ELA: Hm.
Kann ich jetzt das da reingeben?
Dieses?
>> SALLY: Warte. Dafür nehmen wir gleich eine Hilfe.
>> ELA: Von wem?
>> SALLY: Jetzt darfst du
– ja, doch. Schütte es mal so rein.
Warte, noch nicht alles.
Darf ich? Soll ich mal davon ein bisschen machen?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Dass die Schüssel ein bisschen leer wird.
Also wir geben mal so die Hälfte etwa des Mehls dazu.
Genau.
>> ELA: Ein bisschen von dem.
>> SALLY: Milch rein.
>> ELA: Hast du...
Ups!
>> SALLY: Warte kurz.
>> ELA: Oh, meine Hand!
>> SALLY: Ich zeige dir, wie das geht, okay?
Ohne Verschütten.
Warte.
Ich wusste nicht, dass du mitbackst.
Deswegen habe ich die
Hefe
– äh, das war die Milch –
nicht in ein Ausgießgefäß gegeben.
Sonst hätte ich es auch in so einen Messbecher rein.
Okay?
>> ELA: Mama?
Meine Hand.
>> SALLY: Ja.
So.
>> ELA: Jetzt?
>> SALLY: Warte. Wir machen das so.
>> ELA: So viel Milch?
>> SALLY: Ja. Die Milch darf jetzt rein.
Jetzt kannst du es reingießen.
>> ELA: Die ganze?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Guck einmal, immer so gerade halten.
Ja.
>> ELA: So. Und jetzt ist es fertig.
>> SALLY: Gut.
Und jetzt noch das Salz dazu.
>> ELA: Salz.
>> SALLY: Sehr gut!
>> ELA: Zu wenig Salz, Mama.
>> SALLY: Nee, das ist nicht wenig.
Glaub mir, Mama macht gerne Salz rein.
Und jetzt kneten wir den Teig schon mal.
>> ELA: Mama, kann ich noch das...
>> SALLY: Und nicht reinfassen. Das weißt du.
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Und dann geben wir nach und nach
noch das restliche Mehl dazu
und natürlich auch noch das Öl.
>> ELA: Mama, darf ich?
>> SALLY: Warte. Ich hole dir jetzt einen Löffel.
>> ELA: Erst mal das?
>> SALLY: Nein, erst mal das Mehl und dann das Öl.
Warte kurz.
>> ELA: Ich darf nun, nicht?
>> SALLY: Schau mal. Du nimmst jetzt hier Mehl.
So.
Warte, ich zeige es.
Einmal zeige ich es dir und dann darfst du.
Und dann gibst du es hier drauf.
Und dann rutscht es von ganz alleine die Rutschbahn runter.
>> ELA: Hier ist das die Rutschbahn?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Die Rutschbahn. Siehst du?
Hui! Das Mehl darf rutschen!
>> ELA: Ja!
>> SALLY: Hui!
>> ELA: Ja, ja, ja.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Juhu! Das Mehl hat so viel Spaß wie die Ela!
Wir haben hier übrigens Dinkelmehl verwendet.
Aber ihr könnt natürlich auch Weizenmehl benutzen.
Und warte mal. Jetzt gebe ich noch das Öl hier dazu.
Ich gebe es jetzt mal hier rein.
[Musik]
Warte. Mach mal stopp.
Stopp! Stopp!
Das reicht erst mal.
[Musik]
Jetzt hat Ela keine Lust mehr.
Jetzt backen wir alleine weiter.
Also so sieht der Teig jetzt aus.
Es ist ein schöner weicher Teig,
der aber auch nicht klebt.
Und ich knete den immer gerne so sieben bis zehn Minuten.
So wird er wirklich schön geschmeidig.
Ich habe jetzt hier übrigens endlich
die Edelstahlhaken.
Jetzt dürfen sie endlich in die Spülmaschine.
Ich bin sehr glücklich!
Denn die anderen, die musste man immer per Hand waschen.
Ist auch okay.
Aber Edelstahl finde ich einfach
immer einfacher.
Juhu!
So.
Dann einfach den Teig kurz rausnehmen,
zu einer Kugel formen.
Ich besprühe den dann gerne mit Backtrennspray,
damit die Oberfläche nicht trocknet.
Und entweder lasst ihr ihn dann
abgedeckt bei Raumtemperatur für eine Stunde aufgehen
oder bei Gärstufe, wenn ihr habt, im Backofen,
also mit etwas Dampfstoßfunktion.
Dann trocknet er nämlich auch nicht aus
und geht vor allem um das Doppelte schneller auf.
Also spart man sich echt viel Zeit.
Ein bisschen Fett in die Schüssel,
ein bisschen obendrauf.
Und der darf sich jetzt mal schön verdoppeln.
[Musik]
Der Teig ist jetzt wunderbar aufgegangen.
Jetzt braucht ihr nur noch wenige Zutaten,
um das Gericht fertigzustellen.
Ich habe jetzt hier 600 Gramm Schafskäse,
300 Gramm Mozzarella,
etwas Milch zum Bestreichen,
Butter
und vier Eier.
Also traditionell
wird wahrscheinlich kein Mozzarella verwendet, sondern
– ich habe jetzt mal recherchiert.
Es gibt auch verschiedene Arten dieses Gerichts,
dieses Khachapuris.
Denn je nach Region auch in Georgien
wird es anders geformt, es sieht anders aus,
hat anderen Käse drin.
Und zum einen habe ich jetzt gefunden,
dass es den
Sul-
>> AYLIN: Sulguni.
>> SALLY: Sulguni-Käse gibt
und den Imeru-
>> AYLIN: Imeruli.
>> SALLY: und Imeruli-Käse.
Und beide sind sehr würzig.
Und daher dachte ich, dass Schafskäse ganz gut passt
und die Schmelzeigenschaft von Mozzarella ganz gut passt.
Wir probieren es einfach aus.
Und irgendwann werde ich nach Georgien reisen
hoffentlich
und dann probieren wir es einfach aus.
Und dann nehme ich Bezug auf dieses Rezept
und auf dieses Video und sage:
"Ja, es war genau so"
oder "Nein".
Und dann...
Ja.
Aber vielleicht könnt ihr, wenn ihr aus Georgien seid
oder das dort schon mal gegessen habt, mir sagen,
ob die Form genau so war, wie ich es jetzt mache,
oder ob es anders aussah.
Denn, wie gesagt, überall ist es anders.
Und das hier kommt jetzt aus dem Ort, aus einer Region,
bei der ich den Namen auch nicht aussprechen kann.
Deswegen lasse ich es einfach.
Ich blende es hier einfach ein.
Ja, das ist die Art des Khachapuris aus dieser Region.
Okay.
Diese Brote, die werden jetzt relativ groß,
also nicht wie die türkischen Pide etwas kleiner,
sondern wirklich schön groß.
Und man dippt dann sozusagen den Käse auch
direkt mit dem Brot.
Ich werde jetzt hieraus vier Stück zubereiten.
Ich denke, das passt ganz gut.
Ich denke, eine Portion wäre so eine große Portion
für Josh zum Beispiel
oder für zwei Frauen.
Ich habe es da mit den Portionen.
Ja, je nachdem, wie viel man eben isst.
Also hier jetzt den Teig vierteln
und zu Kugeln formen.
[Musik]
Ich war kurz draußen.
Deswegen hatte ich die Teige hier kurz abgedeckt.
Und ich sehe,
sie sind wie beste Freunde zusammengewachsen.
Ja. Ich musste nur kurz nach dem Garpunkt gucken.
Und jetzt
nehme ich diesen Teig, der so wunderschön weich ist,
und rolle ihn oval aus.
Schön groß.
[Musik]
Ja.
Ihr könnt die theoretisch auch auf Pizzablechen backen
Ich wollte es auch zuerst auf den Emaillepizzablechen backen,
aber die sind, glaube ich, einfach etwas zu groß, die Schiffe.
Daher nehme ich jetzt doch mein Lochblech
und so eine Backfolie.
So. Das lasse ich hier kurz liegen,
mache das jetzt ganz kurz mit allen vieren.
Ich finde, so das Arbeiten mit Teig hat echt was Beruhigendes,
vor allem mit Hefeteig.
[Musik]
Ich hatte jetzt nur Babymozzarella da.
Ich versuche, den mal zu reiben.
Aber ich glaube
– ah, doch, es geht.
Ich reibe den Mozzarella.
Natürlich könnt ihr auch großen Mozzarella nehmen.
Aber ich hatte jetzt den da und
wollte nicht extra einkaufen gehen.
Denn ich habe wirklich für dieses Gericht alle Zutaten
immer da.
Schafskäse sowieso.
Mozzarella habe ich nicht immer,
aber das war jetzt Zufall.
Und deswegen wird der jetzt gerieben
und auch der Fetakäse gerieben.
[Musik]
Der Schafskäse lässt sich etwas leichter reiben.
Den Käse habe ich jetzt noch schön durchgerührt.
Oh! Ich habe gerade so vor mich hin geträumt.
Ich glaube, das Rezept schmeckt am besten
aus so einem richtig genialen Steinofen oder Holzofen.
Irgendwann werden wir einen im Garten haben vielleicht.
Okay. Und jetzt einfach nur den Käse vierteln.
Das ist wirklich dann auch eine große Käsemenge da drinnen.
Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass mein Käse gar nicht ausreicht.
Mh.
Ich gucke gleich mal.
Also ich wollte sowieso
erst formen.
Ihr könnt, wenn ihr möchtet, sogar noch
Gouda zum Beispiel zu Sticks schneiden
und dann Käse im Rand noch einbacken.
Hör ich da ein...
>> JOSH: Ja!
>> SALLY: Haben wir Gouda da?
>> AYLIN: Ich glaube, ja.
>> SALLY: Echt?
Was für ein Zufall!
>> AYLIN: Juhu!
>> SALLY: Okay, wir machen Käse im Rand.
Ich will jetzt solche Sticks machen.
Mh. So.
Ja.
Ich hoffe, die sind jetzt dünn genug,
dass ich es auch schön formen kann.
Wenn es nichts wird, lassen wir es halt weg.
Mein Gott, dann war es eine gute Idee, aber...
Vielleicht mache ich sie
halb so lang,
damit es flexibel bleibt
jetzt beim Formen.
Also, da wird jetzt noch Käse im Rand machen,
fange ich jetzt hier noch mal neu an.
Ich zeige es euch hier.
Wir legen den Käse hier hin,
so etwa 2 cm vom Rand weg.
Hier oben nicht,
sondern wirklich nur an die Seiten.
[Musik]
Und jetzt wird hier der Rand umgeschlagen.
Denn ich habe das Bild gesehen von diesen
Khachapuri
und habe gesehen, die haben diesen
wunderschönen dicken Rand.
Und ich glaube, so haben wir einfach schon
diesen schönen dicken Rand.
Und das Ende hier nehmt ihr jetzt
– mh, ich will es ein bisschen schiffförmiger –
und zwirbelt es einfach so.
So.
Ganz einfach.
Und guckt mal.
Am besten formt ihr euch zuerst alle
und dann füllt ihr sie.
Oh ja!
So gefällt es mir gut.
Und da kommt jetzt Käse rein.
Also das Rezept ist definitiv was für Käseliebhaber.
[Musik]
Das wird jetzt nicht sofort gebacken,
sondern wird noch mal abgedeckt,
darf noch ein bisschen aufgehen.
Das heißt, ich mache jetzt hier noch alle anderen fertig
und mache sie jetzt alle mit Käserand.
Aber ich muss kurz Hände waschen.
[Musik]
Die sehen schon gut aus.
Also, wenn ihr sagt,
euch ist das Käse-Brot-Verhältnis zu heftig, dann...
Also,
wenn ihr sagt, ihr seid so normale Käseliebhaber,
dann lasst es ruhig so.
Wenn ihr sagt: "Mensch, ich hätte schon gern
einiges zum Dippen",
dann füllt gern noch die Lücken mit Käse auf.
Ich glaube, das mache ich jetzt kurz und fülle sie noch auf.
Aber ich habe keinen Schafskäse mehr
und keinen Mozzarella mehr.
Da nehme ich jetzt einfach ein bisschen Nomadenkäse.
Wir machen so eine Sally-Art.
Dann mache ich hier noch den Nomadenkäse rein.
Und dann wird euer Rand jetzt noch
mit etwas Milch bestrichen.
Und wie gesagt, decke ich sie ab,
lasse sie noch kurz ruhen
und dann werden sie gebacken.
Und da ist es dann so, dass ich sie backen werde
und so etwa fünf Minuten vor Ende der Backzeit
schlage ich noch ein Ei rein.
Denn so gehört das.
[Musik]
Also jetzt hier nach der Aufgehzeit
einfach den Rand ein bisschen mit Milch bestreichen.
[Musik]
Und dann sofort im vorgeheizten Backofen
oder im Steinbackofen oder Holzofen backen.
Und fünf Minuten vor Ende der Garzeit
schlage ich das Ei rein.
Ich glaube, ich nehme jetzt Pizzastufe.
Aber ihr könnt auch einfach Ober-/Unterhitze nehmen.
[Musik]
Die sehen so gut aus!
Guckt euch das an!
Die ersten zwei Exemplare sind fertig
– fast fertig.
Jetzt kommt hier nämlich in die Mitte ein Loch,
also so eine Vertiefung.
Oh, perfekt ist der Käse geworden!
Richtig gut!
Und da schlage ich jetzt ein Ei rein.
Aber ich schlage es nicht direkt hier rein,
sondern erst mal in ein Schälchen,
damit keine Eierschale auf dem Gebäck landet.
[Musik]
Und so kommt es jetzt wieder zurück in den Backofen,
wird kurz noch mal gebacken,
sodass das Eiweiß stockt,
aber das Eigelb schön flüssig bleibt.
Ich denke,
fünf Minuten sollten reichen.
Vielleicht auch kürzer.
Ich gucke es mir einfach gleich an.
[Musik]
Ich hole jetzt hier einfach noch
ein paar Kräuter aus dem Garten.
Ich glaube, die passen ganz gut dazu.
Ein bisschen Thymian, ein bisschen Minze.
Petersilie wäre eigentlich auch ganz gut.
Aber die habe ich jetzt nicht.
Egal.
Ihr könnt Petersilie noch nehmen.
[Musik]
Fertig!
Jetzt habe ich hier noch Kräuter aus dem Garten.
Gehört, glaube ich, eigentlich gar nicht dazu,
aber ich finde es einfach schön,
wenn noch was Grünes obendrauf ist.
Ich finde es ein bisschen pervers, aber
ich habe gelesen,
dass da noch ein Stück Butter rein muss,
also hier
so.
Aber anscheinend war das auch immer so Seemannskost.
Wartet. Ich brauche eine Gabel.
Und Seemänner brauchen halt Kraft und Energie.
Als ich bräuchte jetzt kein Stück Butter da noch mit rein, denn
der Käse ist ja schon reichhaltig genug.
Und jetzt
schön so.
Och, ich habe es zu lang drin gelassen.
Ein bisschen zu lang
mit dem Ei.
Also fünf Minuten sind definitiv zu lang.
Am besten nur so zwei Minuten.
Aber egal, der Käsedip ist perfekt.
Also meine Mama würde es jetzt so lieben.
Denn die mag keine rohen Eier.
Aber heute, da darf nicht meine Mama probieren,
sondern Sarah!
>> SARAH: Da-dam!
>> SALLY: Komm herein!
Sarah muss auch probieren.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Denn Sarah hatte einen kleinen Fauxpas
>> SARAH: Das kommt gerade richtig,
dieses Essen.
>> SALLY: mit ihrem Essen.
>> SARAH: Es war vergammelt.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Ihr Yufka war vergammelt.
Also hatte sie nur eine kleine Suppe.
Und jetzt kommt das Mittagessen.
Welches findest du schöner?
>> SARAH: Für das Foto oder zum Essen?
>> SALLY: Hm, für das Foto.
>> SARAH: Nimm das.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> SARAH: Ja, da sieht man halt, da ist noch ein Ei.
>> SALLY: Ja, ja. Ich meinte die Form.
>> SARAH: Ach so!
Ja, die Form ist das.
>> SALLY: Das, nicht?
Weil dann schlagen wir da gerade noch ein Ei drauf
und dann machen wir es für das Foto.
>> SARAH: Soll ich das machen?
>> SALLY: Nee, das machen wir gleich.
Jetzt essen wir erst mal.
Wir probieren erst mal.
Also, wie gesagt...
Stellt du dir das so vor, als wäre das Ei noch so halb gar?
>> SARAH: Ich probiere es.
>> SALLY: Halb roh?
>> SARAH: Gehört das so flüssig?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Ja, aber
schmeckt bestimmt trotzdem gut.
>> SALLY: Oder sollen wir auf die nächsten zwei warten
und dann probierst du es?
>> SARAH: Oder wir probieren beides
und ich habe dann einen Vergleich.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Also dann machen wir es so.
Und jetzt macht man es wohl so,
dass...
Warte mal. Ich mache jetzt noch Kräuter drauf,
weil ich es, wie gesagt, schön finde.
>> SARAH: Ah, ist das Minze?
>> SALLY: Dum-dum-dum.
Minze und Thymian.
>> SARAH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und jetzt nimmt man sich von hier außen
so ein Stück und bricht es weg.
Das darfst du auch.
Und dann dippt man das so rein
und isst das.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Brot mit Käsedip.
Und man isst praktisch von außen den kompletten Rand.
Und wenn man innen ankommt,
kann man Gabel und Messer nehmen.
>> ELA: Mama?
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> SAMIRA: Boah, das sieht lecker aus!
>> SARAH: Hm.
Boah!
>> ELA: Mama?
Wir können schon bald.
>> SARAH: Boah!
>> ELA: Mama, ich glaube, die Creme ist schon fertig.
>> SALLY: Echt gut!
>> ELA: Mama, komm! Die Creme ist fertig.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: Komm, hol die mal
>> SARAH: Boah! Das ist
>> ELA: raus!
>> SARAH: Käsefondue de luxe.
>> ELA: Aylin!
>> SALLY: So richtig Käsefondue im Brot.
>> SARAH: Hm.
Ich kriege es nicht raus.
>> SALLY: Mega!
>> ELA: Mama!
>> SALLY: Also, wenn ihr es nachmachen wollt,
unbedingt mal ausprobieren!
Ich mache jetzt gleich die zweite Version
mit nur zwei Minuten Ei.
Und ich glaube, im Holzofen braucht es sogar nur
noch kürzer.
Was war das?
Ich hatte Angst, dass sie niesen muss.
Du auch?
>> SARAH: Ich dachte, die will das Brot anatmen.
>> SALLY: Ach so!
>> SAMIRA: Die wollte was vom Brot abhaben.
>> SALLY: Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Weißt du, was ich noch reinmachen würde?
Ich würde echt so
nach dem Backen eine Knoblauchzehe so ein bisschen reiben
>> SARAH: Boah!
>> SALLY: und so dazu.
>> SARAH: Das würde ich der Butter
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: vorziehen.
>> SALLY: Ich auch.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also mein Tipp:
Ohne Butter, dafür ein bisschen mit Knoblauch.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann einfach dieses leckere Brot genießen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
>> SARAH: Das ist so schön knusprig.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Tschüss!
[Musik]